[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
let me bring in mike florio pro football
talk live co-host
do you understand this mac jones a
trading card that's worth over 100 000
well i guess it's
valued at that amount based upon the
assumption he's going to turn into a
great quarterback if he ends up not
being as good as people think he'll be
then that price is going to plummet i
would say
do you collect cards
i used to i still have all of my cards
back from the 70s tops football cards i
have boxes of them
the year i really got into it was 1976
and
that was the year that the walter payton
rookie card came in
there there are
in my files
for some of the lesser players eight
nine or ten
of them
i ended up that year with one
water pattern rookie card it has kept in
a special plexiglass
case two paulie albeit paulie i'll point
out i'll give it to my son and he'll
lose
all right help me understand what the
rams
did and are doing aaron donald's
contract cooper cups contract jaylen
ramsey got p everybody has gotten paid
matthew stafford's gotten paid
why aren't other teams following the
same blueprint that the rams are are
putting down we joked on monday that les
sneeds f them picks t-shirt
says on the back f that cap
because that's what they're doing now
they're paying their best players and
you can do it if you're willing to do
this and the great patriots teams had
starters and stars who took less so that
they could have backups that they would
pay more to that they had a healthy
middle class of backup talent so when
someone got injured you plug in a guy
who maybe would be a starter somewhere
else and you don't miss a beat the rams
consciously take the risk that if one of
their starters is injured whether it's a
star or just a run-of-the-mill starting
player they're going to have young guys
they're going to have guys on rookie
deals guys making minimum salary that
have to step in and step up that's the
risk they're taking and so far so far it
hasn't burned them but when you get
yourself top heavy with so many star
players taking up so much of the cap
you have to rely upon
young
inexperienced players who are cheap
and
who can come in and get it done you got
to coach them up you got to get them
ready and that's where
the rams i think are making
their their move
having great young players players that
weren't supposedly great who can come in
and play when they need them and they've
managed to keep their guys healthy so
they haven't had to rely on a lot of
these young players to perform how
sustainable is this
until guys start getting injured and
guys miss games and key players aren't
available or you get to a point where
you're paying aaron donald 65 million
over the next two years let's say he
starts to show wear and tear this year
or next year and you're stuck he's
getting 65 million fully guaranteed so
that's where it falls apart if you're
star players the guys you're playing the
most money two aren't getting it done
and one thing to watch if you're a rams
fan dan
that elbow issue with matthew stafford
he hasn't thrown
this off season he had an
anti-inflammatory shot in his elbow his
elbow is a fairly important piece of the
apparatus that allows him to throw the
football they're hopeful he can throw by
training camp but even if he can does it
hold up through the grind of training
camp pre-season not that he'll play much
17-game regular season playoffs what's
going on in that elbow and john wolford
is the backup because you can't afford
to have a 10 million a year backup when
you're relying upon this top heavy
roster of superstars so if stafford for
some reason can't go this year at some
point they got to rely on walford that's
maybe when it all starts to fall apart
anything changed with desean watson
situation based off the new york times
extensive uh article by uh jenny
verentis well i think
you know the one big change is it just
feels like the court of public opinion
is lost for desean watson and never will
be retrieved but
yesterday's big development one day
after
jenny vrent's story mentioned what the
texans did what the texans knew what
maybe they should have known here comes
tony busby represents the 24 women who
have sued watson with a statement saying
i'm bringing the texans to the party now
too now if that statement is made before
the new york times article it has a
different feel
on the heels of the new york times
article when she introduces when jenny
introduces the idea of the texans
potential responsibility it doesn't feel
like ambulance chasing when tony busby
issues a statement it feels valid
because it's been given credibility by
the new york times it was brilliant by
busby to issue the statement when he did
and now dan as these cases go forward
you know the frontline defense by the
texans i think will be we're not
responsible for deshaun watson's
criminal conduct so it puts the texans
in a position where
they may be
joining busby in piling on watson
saying we're not responsible for his
crimes those are his crimes we've got no
duty to the victims of his crimes that's
on him that's a way it could go here and
that may make things even worse for
deshaun watson i'll leave you with this
will there be fallout with uh the
commander's defensive coordinator jack
del rio's comments well look dan i wrote
about this earlier today the question
now becomes when training camp convenes
will del rio still be the defensive
coordinator he's not bill belichick all
due respect as a defensive coordinator
ron rivera is a defensive head coach
the commanders have to ask themselves is
it worth it to us to continue with a guy
who has created this issue stepped on
this rig called the insurrection from
january 6 a dust up and presumably
apologized at the direct behest of team
management i think it remains to be seen
and i know the people out there will cry
cancel culture
that's the buzzword of those who want to
have no responsibility at all for
anything they say or do
it's fair to wonder whether it's in the
best interest of the commanders players
get fired all the time because it's in
the best interest of the team is it in
the best interest of the commanders to
go forward with a guy who created such a
pointless
and avoidable distraction but didn't you
have a politician who said this is the
final nail in the coffin according to
the article you had yeah as it relates
to getting free money from virginia for
a new stadium so to the extent that that
gets them back in line for taxpayer
money and i don't think any of these
owners should be getting taxpayer money
they can afford their own damn stadiums
but if they think it gets them back in
line for some free money for a new
stadium i don't think they hesitate to
move on from jack del rio so i think
once the off-season program ends they
got a decision to make about whether or
not to keep del rio around and it won't
surprise me if they change him and you
know i was very vocal in defending jack
del rio when the raiders secretly lined
up john gruden to replace him while he
was still on the job i think that was
wrong by the raiders and by gruden to do
that but this time around it's his own
fault if he ends up out of a job
good stuff buddy thanks
that's mike florio pro football talk
live co-host we'll take a break phone
calls coming up jim jackson will
get his thoughts on what happened last
night with the celtics and the warriors